peter the proposal and you broke the
news last saturday night i'm just
sitting around minding my own business
checking twitter and i see a series of
tweets from peter king it's like this
looks interesting it's like oh what i
got actually work now on a saturday
night thanks for nothing peter but it
was a great scoop and it was a good
heads up for what was coming and you
know the the
historical piece of this is back in
march april time frame the league had
had toyed with the idea
of
incentivizing the team that does the
hiring that got some significant
pushback folks like tony dungy said why
are we rewarding teams for doing the
right thing
the incentive now is created
to move away from the long-held system
of hiring based on who you know and who
you're related to
and
incentivizing diversity and inclusion
in the lower levels so people have a
chance to show what they can do so they
have a chance to develop and then if
they leave
that's when you get the reward for being
patient and inclusive and breaking away
from the nepotism and cronyism that has
been part of the hiring process for
decades
yeah mike i i i don't think this
uh the new rule in and of itself is
going to motivate let's say the new york
jets to hire eric b enemy because the
jets are saying well there's nothing in
it for us why should we care about the
chiefs getting two third round picks uh
because they developed eric b enemy
this is more as somebody in the league
told me yesterday this is more
do you really believe in career
advancement on your staff do you want to
hold guys back
you know and not sort of let them show
off or
do you really believe in what is best
for the individuals on your coaching
staff as well as what's best for your
team
if you believe
in what's best for the coaches on your
team then what you'll do is you will
allow them to show how good they are you
know you'll allow eric b enemy to get
more and more responsibility if you're
bruce aryans you will put more on byron
left witch's plate let's just say as the
offensive coordinator and so those are
the ways that this rule could help teams
because eventually if bruce arians helps
uh byron leftwich get a head coaching
job bruce aryan says hey we got we got a
couple more third round picks this year
that's going to help us but i i think
it's more of the cumulative effect
as troy vincent talked to me about the
other day and the cumulative effect
meaning
that in conjunction
with the new rooney rule rules this year
which say that every team has to
interview two minority candidates for
head coaching job every team has to
interview at least one minority
candidate for a coordinator job that is
really helped by the nfl to loosen the
log jam
it is an amazing dynamic in the national
football league and it's unavoidable
that you have to
create develop
and enhance the skills of your
apprentices knowing full well
that they may become your arch rivals
before too long and a lot of other
businesses especially smaller businesses
the people in charge they're not going
to show some
some potential future competitor how
it's done right you don't want them
setting up shop across the street from
you even in something as simple as a
bakery we're not showing you what our
secrets are you're going to set up a
bakery across the street in the nfl
that's just that's how it works hey our
best case scenario is to have a staff
full of guys who are going to go
throughout the league and create hell
for us and maybe get us fired eventually
because they're so good and we've helped
get them there and you know that's just
part of the reality of the sport
and this specific aspect of it does
incentivize coaches to ensure that the
minority candidates have the same
opportunities as
the son of the coach as the person who
knows this person who knows that person
who gets their their opportunity that
way i think opening the doors on the
front end and allowing nature to take
its course and allowing people on their
own merit to rise to the levels where
they become noticed by other teams and
may get hired as head coaches that's the
way to fix this once and for all because
the pipeline is always pointed to as the
problem well why hasn't it changed why
aren't there more minority coaches well
who are they who are we going to hire
all the offensive coordinators are white
and oh eric the enemy's still waiting
but i think this will fill more of those
lower positions with minority candidates
and that question of where are all the
best minority candidates to be head
coaches that won't be a question anymore
here's the biggest thing that i got mike
and i'd love to hear your thoughts about
this
okay so in the wake of me reporting this
on saturday night
i got a wave of arguments on twitter and
to the email uh
to emailing me at my column
and they basically said well wait a
second wait a second
why would and i'll use the jets as an
example again why would the jets
incentivize
and and help let's say for instance the
new england patriots by giving them two
third round picks to sign josh mcdaniels
as their next head coach or why would
they help the kansas city chiefs you
know by giving them two third round
picks that's just going to hurt the jets
in the long run and i say
i think that's crazy because let's say
for instance and we'll use josh
mcdaniels as an example okay let's say
that the new york jets take bill
belichick's
guy who handles everything about the
offense and i mean everything okay and
and bill basically he's defense special
teams guy who obviously has a lot to say
about the offense but not on a practice
by practice basis
so now don't you think
that in taking josh mcdaniels away from
the new england patriots you know and
making them have to break in a new guy
after all these years as mcdaniels being
the guy running the total show on
offense that's gonna hurt the patriots
so i think there's that and i also think
there's this
andy reid told me this uh this is three
or four years ago we had we're having a
conversation about head coaches he goes
look you don't worry about all the stuff
about
whether you're hurting your own team
you're you're helping another team
your job when you're hiring a head coach
is only
to get the best guy for that job
everything else is going to take care of
itself
but i think you have identified one of
the potential unintended consequences
and sims and i talked about this earlier
in the week the idea that if you're in
the same division let's say the raiders
were looking for a coach after this
season and we know that they won't be
but let's say that they were
and they're considering the candidates
and they consider eric the enemy
and somebody says well now wait a minute
if we take eric the enemy andy reid's
going to get a couple of compensatory
third round draft picks
well he's going to get him anyway
because somebody's going to hire the guy
so we may as well take him let's take
him away from andy reid make us better
make him worse he's gonna get those pics
anyway let's be the one
instead of somebody from the nfc or one
of the other afc divisions so i don't
see that being a problem if you truly
want the candidate and if the sense is
the candidate is going to get hired now
let me spread it out a little more
broadly because this is an unintended
consequence that can cause significant
issues for all nfl teams if all of a
sudden
the breaks are slammed on hiring any
minority head coach because nobody wants
extra third round picks to be given to
anyone and it becomes an issue not of
race or anything but we don't want the
chiefs getting extra third-round picks
we'll find a coach somewhere else and it
almost becomes a collusive like a subtle
unspoken don't hire any minority coaches
because we don't want anybody getting
extra third round picks i hope the hell
that doesn't happen and here's the thing
here's the thing peter let me just
finish this let me finish this if it
does happen
if that does occur
that will be the proverbial rubicon that
leads to the litigation that should have
been filed against the nfl teams 20
years ago so they better not do it
because this in a certain brilliant sort
of way is a trap
and if you stop hiring minority coaches
because you just collectively don't want
teams to get extra third round picks the
whole house is going to cave in on the
nfl
yeah i definitely could see that but
mike i i i guess i'd make this point
let's say the atlanta falcons decide
that eric b enemy is their guy
and they they go hard after him and they
hire him
the atlanta falcons play the kansas city
chiefs once every four years
and the atlanta falcons you know
the only way they're impacted
by how good the kansas city chiefs get
and
and remember and remember this isn't the
18th pick in the draft this is the 100th
pick in the draft so let's say they get
picks 100 and 101 let's just say okay
and i'm not in any way in any way
minimizing how good those picks are or
what they might become or anything like
that
but
let's just be frank about what
the 100 and the 101st picks in the draft
are
and that is to me if you look at history
probably
a 50 percent chance
of those guys becoming starting players
so let's just say one of them becomes
say machole hardman okay hey that's a
really good player that's a good
contributing player for your team and
good for you but
it isn't like
giving a team the 100 and the 101st pick
in the draft for a team you're gonna
play once every four years it's not like
it's going to ruin the balance of power
either in football or with you versus
them i i think it's a really specious
argument
i i don't disagree with that but you
know the attitude that some have toward
unused draft picks it's the scratch off
lottery ticket mentality
that you don't know what's under that
metallic acrylic paint until you scratch
that pick
could be tom brady who was 199 just
nobody knows and we know
that just like with scratch off lottery
tickets not that i have purchased any
recently but you know what kind of
sitting here thinking about it maybe i'd
like to you know
that it's gonna be
your trash can overflowing with losers
still
that one that you haven't scratched off
yet
could be the one and i think too many
scouts and coaches view draft picks that
way i just i just for the nfl's sake i
hope that there isn't this kind of old
school we don't want anyone getting
extra draft picks we don't like that we
don't want third round draft picks we're
just not going to hire a minority coach
and that's going to be the colin
kaepernicke
kind of
no one ever says it it just never
happens
mood that sets in if that occurs they're
going to have a big problem that's all i
have to say um yeah one other thing
about that yeah
you know mike it might be it might be
tom brady it also might be t martin or
spurgeon winn or chris redman
you know so
i mean you know to think to think that
for everybody to say well you never know
it could be tom brady yes you never know
there could be an earthquake in my
apartment right now and we all could die
i mean you know
it's silly it's silly hire the best guy
for the job period
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports